we'd make a fortune an improv group made
up of superheroes we can take it to
Washington would be the DC Comics
episode 417 Nollan annoyed directed by
the one and only Kevin Smith wasn't
people anything that shines shimmers or
sparkles goes in the back so in this
episode we find the metahuman that the
vote created is null all about that
bling she's a metahuman who can control
gravity and she's also a petty thief Wow
who's been known by multiple aliases and
she's currently stealing a bunch of
valuables in Central City a preacher I
[Music]
need your help here preacher is having
problems with his vibe last so he's come
to get help from Cisco he can't blast
because he's getting old you have to
tell him he's probably gonna send a
knife flying right through my skull
all right let's run it again we got to
make this work does he know that Ralph
Ralph what one more time please follow
Barry's plan you know the one where I
spent hours of my precious time
programming realistic Holograms for you
which Bravo on that by the way thank you
look just more for yourself into Barry
there'll be two flashes thinker won't
know which one is which and will confuse
him kind of a her actually well if
you're missing the point of this
exercise no I get it I was just doing a
little improv but this isn't stand-up
comedy yeah I know that but he should
let it play out it would work you could
then some improving of your own comedy
comes in threes may huh we're trying to
protect you the Vosges coming we need to
be ready all of us okay I still think
it's a pretty good plan I hide my face I
saved my ass
[Music]
everybody the flashes back in there
dropping all kinds of meta references
can you believe that they actually
shouted out DC Comics on the flash now
obviously the way they used it was a
little bit tongue-in-cheek like DC
Comics would be the name of their improv
superhero group if they went to
Washington DC so it's not that they're
saying the DC Comics the Publishing
Group actually exists because they make
all kinds of Marvel references so we
know that within the arrowverse Marvel
Comics exists because they make all
those Hulk and spider-man references but
aside from a Space Ghost comic book that
we saw way back during blast season 1 we
haven't seen a ton of comic books other
than the one that elongated man was
reading earlier this season which is
technically one of DC's imprints so if
you want to nitpick about it you could
say that DC Comics exist within world
but I think it'd be a little too much
for the show to actually say that they
exist like you sort of to tiptoe around
the superheroes referencing themselves
as actual comic books in IP properties
like did you hear Oliver they made a
movie about you what a Green Arrow movie
they're never gonna make a Green Arrow
movie because of the legends finale in
what they just announced on arrow
there's like so much stuff happening
inside the arrowverse right now
obviously because everything's back
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video but obviously like
I said in the trailer the big thing this
week is the new meta No remember there's
only a couple of them left Harrison
wells use the thinking cap to find the
other two so there's still one more
after this but Noel's powers are
basically gravity manipulation in the
funny thing about this too like I said
that the legends finale was last night
they took a big swipe at the Hawks those
stupid chiken people really great heat
wave line
as Huayra picked us not the professor
and those stupid all flying chicken
people the null character in the comics
debuted during the Hawk World title but
the thing about her powers on the TV
show is that the thinker already can
manipulate gravity using his chair like
he has special repulsors on it so the
real question is is what do you need
gravity manipulation for is there
something that he's going to try and
raise up off of the ground
so really her powers are more practical
there's really only a couple of the bus
metas that have really powerful
abilities that stack when you use them
all together at the same time so like
Kilgore for instance the ability to
invade any kind of technology then you
have hazards ability which can spread
that over a large localized field
so like Kilgore can control technology
within a single city but you use that in
combination with hazards ability and
eventually that would spill over to the
entire world so the thinker would be
able to control technology on the other
side of the planet but you start to see
like if he's going to evolve the human
race forcibly like that's this whole
idea the Enlightenment they call it that
there are a couple of abilities that
stack it's not totally clear how
gravitational powers are part of that we
know how ralph did knees powers are
important because he can get his old
body back he can turn back into the
kneel salyanz' version of the thinker
but the only thing I'm really worried
about is them just going a little too
over-the-top a really good example of
one of the medes that just became a
little too arch in their portrayal was
blacksmith Katee Sackhoff is an amazing
actress she's not so great drama all the
stuff she did on Battlestar was badass
all the stuff she did on Longmire was
amazing
but her blacksmith character like the
fake British accent it's just a little
too much so hopefully when they get to
season 5 they'll have the directors on
set just like rain the actors in a
little bit like you go in a little too
over-the-top it was a funny story on the
set of Thor Ragnarok when they were
shooting that fake play where Loki is
pretending to be Odin and he's being all
silly so you have the actor Anthony
Hopkins performing as a fake version of
himself trying to be Loki in the
director taiga actually said that he had
to tell Anthony Hopkins during a couple
takes that he was being too over-the-top
like you're giving me too much and so
Anthony Hopkins is like okay great I'll
bring it back
just a little bit oh [ __ ] my son fall
has returned readings my boy so usually
when stuff like that happens it's the
job of the director as they're doing
scenes to tell the actor to bring it
back just a little bit like you're
giving me too much so usually it's the
directors job on set to prevent stuff
like that from happening but the other
big thing in the episode obviously is
all this breacher stuff so Danny Trejo
is always great when he comes on
obviously they're playing him mostly for
comedy and the reason he comes back
based on this trailer is because he's
just getting old he's losing his ability
meaning that within the Canon of the
show even though the Gypsy character has
been cast on another TV show and she's
not as available to guest star in
episodes as she was before she'll take
her father's place on earth 19 as the
leader of the breachers that tracked
down people that jump to other planets
which is like still very very illegal on
their planet but the thing about this
episode is they said that [ __ ] does not
appear even though she's heavily
referenced she'll come back later this
season and it's sort of like a tag into
what's happening in this episode because
Cisco is like the guy that has to
deliver the bad news to breach her hey
dude you're getting old you're not gonna
be able to hunt people down and stab
them anymore but you can kind of see how
that ties in thematically with the
thinker's arc this season he has this
disease that's eating his mind alive so
he's stealing all these other powers to
make himself more powerful so that he
can prolong his life to accomplish his
goal whereas I think what they're gonna
try and do with this breacher storyline
is that he will eventually accept it
burr grudgingly like he's not gonna go
without a fight
but eventually Cisco's probably gonna be
able to convince him like okay step
aside let your daughter take your place
and be in charge there's only six more
episodes including tonight's episode so
we are like right around the corner for
finding out what the hell is going on
with coffee shop girl - so don't be
surprised if she has some sort of tag
during this episode or a next week's
episode we don't know when she's coming
back but we do know that we're gonna
find out what's going on with her really
really soon
but what'll happen is is there's brand
new infinity war so I'll post that next
then I'll post my flash episode later
tonight so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel if you haven't
done that but click here for my legends
of tomorrow finale video and click here
for brand new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you
tonight